President Trump plans to address the
nation this morning Paula Reid is at the
White House was more on that Paula have
you heard yet what time he expects to
address us and what do we expect to hear
from the president today we do not yet
have a time gale but this is significant
because this will be the president's
first public response to these
retaliatory strikes the last night the
president tweeted appearing to try to
assure Americans that quote all is well
but just hours before these strikes the
President issued a warning to Tehran to
stand down he told reporters that if
Iran did anything that they shouldn't be
doing they were going to be quote
suffering the consequences and very
strongly but it's unclear exactly what
that would entail but CBS News has
learned that last night the president
was here at the White House with his
national security team including vice
president Mike Pence defense secretary
mark s / Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
and his national security advisor Robert
O'Brien now Pompeo he has been the main
voice in this administration's defense
of the strike that killed sulamani he
has long advocated for aggressive action
in the region and he's helped champion
what he calls the strongest maximum
pressure campaign in history against
Iran but as the president addresses the
nation today he's walking a fine line
with his base he campaigned on a promise
to pull the u.s. out of these so-called
forever Wars and so far he has not
publicly shared the evidence that
prompted him to escalate this conflict
with Iran Gail we're all waiting to hear
about that thank you very much Paula
you